danielle's in daytona hi danielle how
are you
hey i'm good thank you chris and dave
for having me i appreciate it sure
what's up
um so i kinda have to tell you what
you're gonna say um
so i just my husband and i just got
married
um in september of this year um
last year it's been um it's been crazy
which has helped um
he is a patient of mayo clinic now um
but he was uh liam has lost them last
year as well in icu
um and we just adopted my step nephews
last year so things have just been
chaotic
um and the situation that we have is we
don't have credit cards thankfully
but we are right now paying for three
vehicles
and one of them is
garnishing my husband's wages
and i it's my fault i
i'll take the blame for it um and i feel
horrible as
a wife as south um but i
can't figure out how to get out of this
why do you take the blame for his car
getting repossessed
um well we voluntarily recode it um
it was my fault i thought the grass was
greener
i wanted a newer vehicle and with our
credit at the time
the dealership wasn't going to have it
with us being so far upstairs down
so they're like well the only option for
you guys to get out of this
monstrous van is if you guys maybe
would you know how long ago was it
repo'd
um two years ago and then they what's
the debt what's the deficit balance how
much do you owe
16 000 okay do you have any money at all
no no no we just got married we just
finalized adoption we're
we're paycheck to paycheck and what's
your household income
um almost 70. okay
so i hear a whole series of things that
you're doing that you can't afford to do
and you did them anyway
yeah when are you going to stop that
um yeah are you yeah absolutely
okay are they i thought you said he was
at mayo
so there's his company still paying him
he's a
he's a patient um they
so he was out of work for about how much
does he make a year
uh he makes 38. is he back at work
he just returned back to how much do you
make a year
i make almost 30. what you need to do
scratch together about 1500 to 2
000 and offer that as a settlement on
this
because repos bring somewhere around a
nickel to a dime on the dollar
on the deficit that's what you can
settle it for in a lump sum
in writing and for goodness sakes kiddo
get your hands around this stuff